what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch the latest trailer
for shang chi and i'm just freaking
grateful this did not come out at 5
30 in the morning we can enjoy it in the
evening
anywho very excited for this pinoy pride
i hope there's a couple of filipinos in
this one
let's do it
[Music]
throughout my life
if you want them to be yours one day you
have to show me you are strong enough to
carry them
um
rings man yeah
yes i'm so excited she's in this
razer fist
[Music]
i don't think they show fang boom in the
trailer
all you need is that little glimpse boy
oh hell yeah
wait a minute
gotta go back it looks like abomination
we're not 100 sure it looks like
abomination well and with the multiverse
opening up i mean it could just be a
slightly revised or slightly nastier
version of the character because it
like there's a lot of similarity there
it looks like well i believe emil
blonsky's supposed to appear in the
she-hulk movie but anyway like that's a
big surprise
and think fangboom i'm surprised we saw
that i really thought they would wait
until the actual
movie to unveil uh such a thing as far
as what we're getting here with the
trailer so far
man it just looks like a damn good asian
cinema
film with the marvel flavors throughout
i'm loving the cinematography by bill
pope that looks great but yeah you know
what i'm kind of getting vibes of have
you guys seen the show my hero academia
a little bit of the position that
shangqi is in
sort of reminds me of todoroki this guy
who has these powers
and it's like yeah i like my mom i love
my mom and i got a horrible relationship
with my abusive father but i gotta
accept i do got to accept some of the
things and skills and the parts of me
that are
are like my dad i imagine there's a bit
of a psychological
progression you'll have to go through in
terms of being like
i have to learn to take what's good that
i learned from my dad
primarily my badass fighting skills
and also um you know learning and big
part of letting go some of the bad stuff
is you have to accept that you have some
of those qualities like shang chi looks
like beyond more than just the
the cool charismatic guy that see me lou
is he has a darkness in him he has an
edge in him
that i'm very much excited to explore
here and the fight scenes and visuals do
look great but what i thought was really
most impressive to me about this trailer
is the reset up the reintroduction of
the mandarin
the ten rings john tell me did not think
those ten rings looked excellent those
looked rad and yeah as a recent
textualization for what they can be in
this new iteration and also going off
the fact that you know we had the
fake mandarin with his finger rings like
yeah to recontextualize it and to build
upon it looks
pretty awesome yeah it looks like the
perfect way to sort of recontextualize
this for the now because
i don't know there's just something so
much more badass about watching those
shots and then like
linking together and falling down and
then you think like well with all the
different powers combined like what are
the capabilities well looks like we're
going to have some just incredible
action set pieces even before
we get to this established tournament
but the showdown that they're building
up it's been a
while since i can think of a standalone
marvel movie
where i'm going i cannot wait for the
finale fight between the protagonists
antagonist oh yeah which is what you
would want for
just a good martial arts film generally
speaking but for a marvel standalone
film that's an element of this that i
wasn't expecting to walk away from this
trailer
anticipating here i'm not sure what the
choice of reason is to have
the music of like this this rap r b
music for
for this film for me it doesn't
personally fit the flavor of the trailer
because it feels so like
traditional martial arts epic and then
you got this like rap music lineup
so it doesn't quite vibe with me but
maybe if the music is featured in the
actual film itself
i might enjoy it a little bit more but
as it stands yeah this is uh this is
super impressive
oh yeah well and just the array of
different like martial arts movies
scenarios like you know they're having
the scaffolding fight it looks there's
gonna be some foot chases some
car you know like weaving through the
streets of the city and then you go
further and you get your fighting
tournament stuff your battle between
father and son it looks like it's really
going to encompass so many different
kinds of fight scenes that you would see
in a martial arts
cinema type experience but then fused
into
the scope and scale and the science
fiction of marvel and it looks
like a pretty interesting blend with
even some of those like you know martial
arts epics
the sort of like chinese opera style
epics blended in for maybe some of the
flashbacks and stuff like that like it
really looks like they're going
comprehensive with this film inspiration
i gotta say man looking at this one shot
of fing fang foom that is an
imposing ass image because like whenever
i imagined it i was like a big green
dragon
oh yeah it's perfect do it underwater
this is kind of
much more this is a terrifying image
when you just look at it
alone yeah and uh i wonder how it'll
ultimately play out in the film itself
with the ten rings i don't feel
i feel like when shanxi wins he's
probably gonna win
i feel like he would would he take on
the ten rings do you guys think he would
actually take on the ten rings because
as much of a legacy as it's made for his
family it's also soon to be a bit of a
curse that runs through
the blood of his family too and
considering his father seems to wield so
much of his power through the ten rings
doesn't strike me as the kind of guy who
would
well we'll see it might be interesting
to have shawn nah i wouldn't want shanxi
to be relying on the 10 rings
he's already the greatest i i like what
we know about chongqi already as the
greatest martial artist in the marvel
cinematic universe maybe we will see the
shadow clone effect but ultimately this
is a film that
has this interesting backdrop about
family and sins of our fathers and
accepting your past a lot of interesting
stuff on display
i'm so happy
it looks really cool my only real
complaint is i'm not sure about the
music choice in the trailers
yeah but guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button
and of course uh it's the end of the
month so i wanted to give a little bit
of a shout out to the patrons who are
pledged at our
deleted text and bts tier stock
stockrook
cliff rodriguez david alexander
chris bustin mr crispy
stoned pc oh danny pancakes
alex biewer kathleen maya
pseudonymous entity olivia delgade
sane nash sonadiki
khali hallease jacob gonzalez
lily levitt odell josh
josh barnes shawn davis oscar
lauren american horse thank you guys so
much for pledging to our patreon page
and showing your support at the level
that you
are sincerely it uh it means a lot to
have you here
and it helps out the channel more ways
than you realize
so i'm very grateful hopefully you've
watched some of the stuff that we post
exclusively at that too
only this is what you're here for but uh
i happen to give you a little shout out
guys thank you so much sincerely thank
you